souvenez vous que les heures précédant
la radio affronter beaucoup de vagues
des mines de ton espèce depuis l'aube il
totalement dégueulasse pour pouvoir
enfin accéder au temple et sauver ses
amis
elle a alors un ami qui l'a pas mal aidé
un autre qui a réussi à s'échapper du
temps qui s'est fait littéralement
défoncé par les ennemis elle va alors
vouloir accéder au temple en passant pas
en dessous le pont avec mamie qui la
coupe bien évidemment toujours fighters
sauf que savoir un petit peu faible elle
va se retrouver dans une espèce est
propre
bon alors savoir si elle a réussi à dido
tombe si elle a pu sauver ses amis et
surtout si elle même s'en est sorti du
banc of you de monde c'est squeeze l'on
se retrouve aujourd'hui pour l'épisode 7
de notre aventure sur tomb raider donc
on retrouve lara croft c'est quoi
et puis voilà alors c'est un truc je
rappelle qu'on était juste là sur le
pont qui doit être situé ici à travers
la roche
on a failli mourir dans le vide et on
était couvert par notre ami on arrivait
ici fin bref bon au pire vous checkez 8
fait vous avez vu le résumé en début de
vidéo ou pas j'en sais rien alors c'est
parti se retrouve un petit peu dans la
même situation que ben vas-y pourquoi tu
hésites tu as juste de mourir alors ça
ça fait penser comme je disais dans le
tout premier épisode souvenez vous on a
vu un cas similaire pareil la flotte
presque jusqu'au plafond a à peine
respirer
sachant qu'en plus la flamme doit
consommer l'oxygène et que d'après la
réaction chimique albert costa
alors
voyons voir où cela va nous mener je
rappelle qu'on devait l'automme sauver
notre ami par nos amis dont un cas voulu
avec s'échapper qui est mort en tombant
dans le vide qui a fait mal
d'ailleurs je n'en croyais pas mes yeux
les joueurs de lapin intervint pas bon
alors entrées de la cote
l'aco sauver les membres d'équipage de
l'endurance capturer tout à fait alors
de chemin à gauche ou droit à gauche ah
d'accord
pourquoi j'ai choisi le mauvais chemin
vous m'en direz des nouvelles
aux high serré quand vous y maintenant
je donne des coups de flèches dans des
coupures et sommes pas obligés de faire
quand tu es un coup de piolet
non non
la secte la bâche solari les enfants de
lavey de soleil a neigé pour une raison
je sais que vous aspirez être vivre je
sais que vous voulez quitter cet endroit
même mais pour y parvenir nous devons
libérer notre entraîneur et on fait
comment nous elle est prisonnière
c'est en la libérant que nous nous
limiterons cette vie le sens de cette il
coule dans ses veines voir être la cré
le rituel des flammes à nous montrer la
vérité emiko tamure brûler avec témoin
campus à la vache folle voire bain
tu actu est notre frère
maintenant fait
s'il vous plaît
les bété nicolaï a menés là moi ouais
c'est fait exploser [ __ ] la vache
waouh s'était arrêté juste avant ça dans
l'épisode d'avant quand même on a loupé
quelque chose qui se fait littéralement
violet sur place incroyable kwenge un
morceau de captage parlait même pas
j'étais tellement à fond dedans que vous
alors toutes les créatures du monde de
vos phrases se massent noter que leur
fille et deux touchés je ne désapprouve
pas cette réaction
je fais seulement ça depuis beaucoup
plus longtemps que toi
préparez-vous complètement tard elle va
bientôt
il regarde
regarde pas
elle est l'élue
bientôt mes frais
ça rend les bras alors aillent là dans
la salle du tronc what the fuck
littéralement what the fuck
elle est l'élue y avait une espèce de
gros manques a éteint le feu
j'aimerais comprendre what the fuck
[ __ ] c'est il est complètement barré
franchement
on n'a pas ch c'est un bain de sang ça
c'est quoi
d'accord ok c'est vraiment un bain de
sang comme [ __ ] c'est pas trop glauque
s'écoule sans voix
ok bon on se retrouve dans un bain de
sang absolument génial où allons nous
aller alors à la prendre c'est de plus
en plus glauque il est de plus en plus
boîte de fuck au final ce tomb raider ou
allons-nous 100 mecs bon on continue
alors on va aller j'ai plus de flèches
je suppose que j'ai plus d'autre à
manger plus rien bon d'accord à des
flèches a fait 5 ce gaz naturel ça
surement péter si je fais ça voilà parce
que le fait le gars ça fait boum et
tchad ou à l'apache
ouais j'ai en vidéo maintenant quand je
parle tout ça c'est que ça en vidéo
ben non ouais
bush et demain dimanche soir et dimanche
le salon week-end de pâques qui a pas
courageux c'est dimanche va quitter
mamie ya peu près autant pour moi ma
mère était venue me dire pas nue alors
qu'on refasse péter et concours directs
dedans je crois comme ça voilà hop
ok on est bon alors on adjani kg et deux
flèches peur qu'on fasse gaffe on va lui
mais ce truc avoir des matériaux voilà
moi on est riche on me pour améliorer
plein de choses bon allez je vous fais
folie ouais pas possible
ben si on la l2 gré de folie qu'il est
peut être parvenu malgré lui à une
certaine forme de clairvoyance
l'hélicoptère n'est pas la solution je
le sais là au fond de toi je dois
prévenir les autres si vous embarquez
dans l'hélico nous sommes morts
j'ai pas d'ombré pourquoi elle a dit que
s'ils embarquent dans les coulisses sont
morts parce qu'à chaque fois il ya une
tempête qui s'abat sur véhicule oui
peut-être
ah on a des nouvelles améliorations gens
tombent alors on a tous su mon âge le
piolet sur le même et du coup a vu qu'on
a plus les autres armes sur nous on peut
pas les améliorer bon on fait chier bon
on va continuer y avait un petit
l'assaut par terme sa lecture de du
let's play alors pour info on est déjà
34% du jeu skate ya quand même pas mal
bon à la fin de ces épisodes on devrais
je pense à 45,6 on avance bien et
écoulement alors ou devons-nous aller
encore du chemin
elle va se faire attaquer par quoi par
des loups ouah
pas que alors ils vont pas vers moi moi
ils me font peur
ils ont failli manger un humain la tâche
de sauver déjà le mec tu vas qu'il est
mort jeudi sauvé c'est une blague je lui
ai sauvé la vie quoi je peux le pas un
truc a pas d'effets les choix de ce
qu'on va se retrouver vite embêté [ __ ]
de merde c'est quoi ces mecs qui venait
le manger regardez les sondages
regardez il a était rouge et son coude
c'est dégueulasse
c'est un projet parole à l'ats ils vont
être là partout c'est quoi ça il a dit
que c'était chez lui mais il vit dans
une d'autres ont déjà du gaz mais c'est
quoi ce délire les gens bon allez hop on
va prendre sa caisse a alors à cheval
chez d'affaires georges voiles tous les
vols aller saute
ok je peux pas ramasser non et la barbe
je fais comment aïe ça fait mal
[ __ ] mais védrine qui les flèches pour
rien le gaz en fait
la fasch hockey à manger ça lui porte
puis j'étais en état de choc je
comprends pas ce qui se passe bon alors
attendez ne me laisse pas comme ça moi
[ __ ] d'avoir mes claques et passer un
à wigan
ok parfait a de quoi sûrement nous
sortir d'ici là on va faire péter la
porte tu poses way parts et enfonce se
casse de ceux de ce sceau du main à
putte un match très très glauque jeu ttc
monde pour qu'on entend être cet endroit
voilà je n'avais pas faut que je prenne
ça moi oh la vache
l'accord merde au dos
oh lalala lalala les gens je voulais la
faire là à la james bond et où je me
suis défoncé c'est sa survie en plein
toi bien sûr feu d'artifice ont bel et
bien tu puisses à meerbeke
allez hop dans la tête c'est bon bon ça
lance en effet pas mal
alors on va se faire masser aulas on a
intérêt à se brouiller la safer père est
mort
merde à allah ça c'est le truc un peu
tôt on a mis au point mais tu laisses
allez tiens voilà voilà [ __ ] il en
fallait des coups de poing dans la
gueule pour moi celui de la vache
alors pour hamas hop hop hop hop
alors on s'en bat les couilles au revoir
alors qu'est ce que c'est que ça ok gros
spot kind of faith falloir faire péter
la porte je suppose ok à cette fois je
crois que se servent à rien ok on peut
monter on va faire la caisse bout du
compte j'ai oublié de faire une crise
qui étaient là-bas autre façon c'était
que de l'xp a priori qui avait deux ans
ou pas dans le spot excuse moi j'étais
j'ai l'âge et oui désolé j'ai je
m'excuse alors qu'est ce qu'on va faire
hop on doit aller là-haut absolue qui
lui aurait dit gasquet du gaz aussi aux
maisons
d'explosion dire les débloquer alors
comment ok vin sauté dessus je pense un
feu de camp ça sert à rien nature pas
plus de d'armes que notre petit arc
malheureusement aux caisses de munitions
c'est fait ok on y va alors il va
falloir qu'on saute pour la vache par
des cons c'est sûr ça à mon avis waouh
ok une fois qu'on est là il peut aller
là où très bien nickel bond un peu de
chances d un passage au dessus comme par
hasard j'ai cette paix en terre
qu'est ce qu'ils valent voulait voir
triple kill et voilà c'est un tout
bloquer
c'est sympa moi j'ai bien aimé c'était
mignon
bon on va rester en hauteur plutôt bien
les premiers matériaux je préfère ne pas
aller les prendre et rester en vie
tous deux tombés là haut allez hop alors
on va remonter un petit peu alors du
coup ils ont amené à travers la salle du
trône qu'est ce que la salle du trône
est-ce que c'est l'élu où je sais pas
celle qui va un peu régner sur l'île
maintenant j'ai pas tout compris en tout
cas chez qu'elle avait beaucoup de cul
parce qu'à la base le vent ça ça quand
même ravi un peu le feu et là ça fait
tout l'inversé
oh [ __ ]
ok on a eu sur la voie je fais pas tout
le temps calmes alors aulas vaches
oh [ __ ] ils sont morts comme des
crêpes quoi genre normal oh merde je
suis désolé mec j'ai acheté un chef au
cas où tu trahis les brûler [ __ ] mais
mourir brûlé les gens se veut être
tellement affreux aux jeunes est prise
d'envoyer j'avais pris ce aux flèches
c'est plutôt good quoi d'autre n'a rien
à explorer sinon ce sont des rats merde
j'aimerais bien juste l'avoir voir ce
que ça fait
oh non je prends ça petit peu gras est
mort alors attendez on a nos flèches on
a un levier ici qui vont ouvrir le gaz
qu'on va devoir faire péter comme d'hab
bouge de là
ok alors j'ai pas très bien compris à
quoi ça servait qu'on me fasse péter
faudrait a priori attendait
ce qui n'a pas un truc à faire
d'accord ok mais rld
oh là là là là c'était ingénieux là
j'aurais jamais pensé qu'il fallait
faire ça
moi tout va plus vite avant leur temple
pour aller là bas wen mois de mode
lalalalalalalalala et voilà comme d'hab
ils tombent toujours dans les endroits
un peu un peu barré moi et c'est pour ça
qu'ils sont tous fous ils se mettent des
grosse cuite avec du gaz ils sont
marrant ça le rend fou forcément
je ne cache jamais là-bas ok michael pas
tout à fait c'est bon là gages
waouh j'ai su alors mcgraw bois je
retiens nord mais [ __ ] mais les
flèches enflammées selon s'est enflammée
[ __ ] voilà comme ça
l'homme qui sont bien tous alors
attendez soupapes loi ok cinématiques
bon voyage potter à dakar hier
comment y arriver jusqu'ici on m'a aidé
ghrib
oui ça n'est pas sorti
clairement
je le croyait invulnérable il s'est pas
laissé faire
il m'a permis d'arriver jusqu'à vous un
hélicoptère de sauvetage est en route
sam est enfermé ailleurs vous avez des
nouvelles de whitman visiblement il
n'est pas dans la chambre d'à petit
monsieur showbiz a dû réussir à se faire
surclasser on le trouvera essam aussi
mais il faut déjà qu'on sorte de la
taille 9 passes entre les barreaux la
solution
alors attention
ok alors comment est-ce qu'on va devoir
faire
ah je sais on les a entendu parler d'un
oh yeah
d'accord et maintenant je sais faire
quoi sapin
bien servi si le sol commence à chercher
fait non seulement sortir de là
j'aimerais bien mais je réfléchis
actuellement e où je pourrais faire ça à
la bâche un truc pour monter là-haut là
bas
attendez [ __ ] même pas passer d'une
pierre portefeuille
ok par là allez hop on y va on y va dans
son sens tac
heureusement que c'est laraque avec moi
maintenant on fait quoi
pourquoi il est bloqué par là ok alors
ouais t'as la vache il donne vraiment la
grippe ont cru qu'un le mode aide comme
ça [ __ ] montrer ce nom alors est ce
que je dois faire avec deux pêcheurs
voilà hockey
dac saint gilles en même temps bon je
suis sur ma belle
voilà à sa voix qui joue ok moi je
regardais j'étais à fond dedans
voilà là
à soient prudentes
ça va tout va bien
ça brûle les lèvres des pieds je tends
la main
ok je sais je sais je sais je sais oui
oui je me dépêche vous stressez pas les
fermes ta gueule
jo
genre genre non non là j'y crois pas
mais pas une seule seconde quoi voilà
allegro coco ho [ __ ] mais ça olalala
mais c'est le bordel dans cet épisode
mais qu'est-ce qui se passe [ __ ] oh là
là là où tu mets tout
un point de rencontre de l'autre côté du
pont l'hélico qui ne devrait pas c'est
la loi du 2 qui faisait ça vous fait on
a tous les ans plus tard
olala maître d'oeuvre et mans depuis
longtemps la passe moi
heureusement que le jeu a fait vivre a
quand même allé au fond moi ça
ok donc on a carrément pété leur temple
je suis choqué
moi je suis déjà prêt alors sauté dessus
je ramasse tous les matériaux à l'ailé
gauche
ah merde
ok par la fenêtre hop allez zou ou olala
il ya tout qui paie tout en lavant
provoqué la reine
- oh la la la la la la
adieu
mais fallait aller où ils ont maritime
est face à un mur dans une congère
pourtant sortir ses droits avaient
subitement à ok pour vous souhaiter sont
aussi d'accord ok comme ça en fait hop
non même pas s'ils allaient non c'est
pas ça
alors je comprends pas qu'on est là
qu'est ce qu'on fait moi je suis allé là
sur toile a bon dos et un autre tout con
d'accord voilà c'est bien ce que je
disais un truc tout con mais alors mais
tous pourris elle accroche toi ok mais
calme voilà c'était vraiment tout pourri
quoi
la nouvelle reine et dans sanctuary faut
qu'ils arrêtent leurs délires avec la
boj à je te rejoins tas je me dépêche
trouvé ça me saoule commencer l'an un
peu défaut le gameplay
laisse moi m'en sortir
toujours avancer
or diable pourquoi le truc qui étaient
fondées sur des fuites de gaz et cetera
j'aimerais bien savoir la petite
histoire histoire coton et défèquent
harmon trop belle idée pour que le
palais dur bien devoir elle construit
sur des échappements de gad sa première
enchère à ok faut juste aller sur la
barre du tout d'accord lines ap hockey
nickel up aller fonce à la waho c'est
beau c'est le bordel mais c'est beau
mais [ __ ] la mort
tout le monde meurt autour de la sof
elle alors l'a ravagée tu survis
accroche-toi route coco route super bien
c'est [ __ ]
ça mathias
personne ne part
j'ai entendu ça en japonais avant que
l'avion s'écrase
le rituel du tombeau de himiko et
pourquoi matthias y redire est-il
elle prend le temps quand même au milieu
des flammes moi georges avait pris le
temps
julienne [ __ ] c'est la guerre c'est la
guerre voilà la vache
tu fais quoi toi moeurs connard à
l'achat
waouh je crois qu'il n'a pas aimé que tu
soit apparemment mais c'est pas censé le
brûler les flèches en feu bordel sa part
en cacahuète histoire
bougez l'arrêt ouvre le dernier met la
tête mais ta sale tête mais ta sale tête
de merde base ils sont lourds c'est bon
les mecs à l'hérésie up dégage ça en
fait un mois [ __ ] faut que je passe
par houla faut que je sois au toqué
comme ça il ya tout qui tombait tout
affolant non elle avait un mec en bon
tant pis si tampico et matériaux là pour
qu'on n'a pas trop le temps oui stressé
il ya du feu partout ça a tout pété la
halle et rennes court pour coco la voie
là là là là je me sens tellement pas
aussi enfin je veux dire ça va vous
n'avez rien dès qu'ils ont cessé de nous
voir comme une menace
j'ai pu me déplacer comment vous étiez
au courant pour les autres ça mais là
bas mais il m'aurait fallu une arme pour
la libérer ses salariés ce sont des
merveilles
trop logique bras ce sont des
psychopathes docteur whitman il faut
qu'on ait nos amis à son futur jeu je
fais le cas ici vous vous me dites quand
la voix est libre
aulas il est bizarre lui bien que ton
malade ce mec
je crois que tu ne comprends pas tu as
été choisie samantha c'est un grand
honneur pour toi pour nous tous
certains commençaient à perdre la foi
mais tu es arrivé je vous en prie vous
croyez que je suis spécial mais je ne
suis pas je ne veux pas être choisi mais
il ne s'agit pas de ce que tu veux il
s'agit de ce que tu es le sens de himiko
coule dans ses veines
je crois que tu as mal à vous êtes vous
maintenant pourquoi faites vous face du
cherche la logique et la raison là où il
n'y en a pas j'ai fait la même erreur
autrefois je croyais que les bateaux
pourraient arriver jusqu'à nous et que
les avions ne s'écraserait pas je veux
rentrer chez moi
ap tout comme moi ça fait des années que
j'attends ce moment c'est ma vie que
j'ai donné tu crois pas que je n'ai pas
essayé de bâtir ici de cécile d'un sont
analysés sommes pris au piège et trois
semaines tu as le pouvoir de nous
libérer de tout cela
nombreux sont ceux qui ont perdu leurs
actes à désirer un tel temps l'un 110
propage l'autre fille a disparu
à
il est temps d'en finir dimitri tu ne la
quitte pas des yeux
voilà fixés symbole bizarre et tous se
sont manqués
dieu merci tu es là
howie [ __ ] celui qu'elle échoue mais
ces armes super il faut qu'on parte
avant qu'il revienne
whitman
parce qu'il est passé
moi j'étais sûr qu'il allait se faire
buter lui ou qui a eu un rabin christ
est pas possible
ok retourne dans la salle du trône
côté des sables se revoit une sortie là
ok alors comme d'hab des vagues
d'ennemis
on note vraiment vagues d'ennemis [ __ ]
j'me sens sérieux
enfin un concert dans toute bordel qui
m'énerve c'est qu'ils lancent des
pétards on les appelait les artificiers
déjà artificiers pardon elle me gave
regardez le 1 mais mon gars montré
qu'ils avaient sans will all où ça va me
prendre la tête histoire
oh là là là il ya un million d' ennemi
[ __ ] mais oh mais j'y crois pas quoi
alors qu en fait partie c'est direct pas
d'avs
oh la la mairie tout au fond tout ça bon
oui on est dans la merde
j'annonce
oh lalalalalalalalala comment on va
faire on fait une femme tue ses
maîtresses
bon ok de l'artifice va chier [ __ ]
artificiers business ouais bah voilà
tiens c'est une espèce ces poissons
doucement [ __ ] la vache on est dans le
caca
on est dans le caca jusqu'au cou c'est
bon les a tous eu [ __ ] des masters
on va mourir là c'est pas possible là
non mais ils sont sérieux mes mecs mais
commenté je vais tuer d'appellation paix
comme un gros lot ferme ta gueule
voilà un mot
monte oh là là non plus leur tirer
dessus aussi en fait aux [ __ ] yomou
show johnny et la grecque comme pièce la
compétence que j'ai appris alors c'est
bon et d'ail
qu'est ce qu'on fait échappez vous de
cet enfer sais pas où c'est là-bas ok
c'est vraiment un défi 3 du tram à ce
vide yes j'ai eu les trois pièces
diffusées à pong trop bien il pouvoir
améliorer mon continue je crois la
lumière j'avais 20 ans j'en peux plus
aller trouver un moyen de sortir du
palais je veux que ça sortir des stands
faire une connerie bordel
voyez pas qui est tout petit pet les
gardiens au nom d' accor tient ferme au
prix et exécute avec un coup d'oeil aux
länder file au but mais qui n'était pas
mort perf outre hockey direct au alors
ça les gens alors vous mettez tous trois
un ter 3e tranche 3a et puis quoi aulas
il a pris tellement cher cela fait alors
jamais deux fois de passer
bush à les retrouver
d'ailleurs vous avez vu au mcdo dans le
match là tu viens de sortir j'ai assez
rigolé quand j'ai vu ça je m'accroche
excellent excellent allez on va bientôt
sortir j'en suis sûr la dernière petite
vague d'ennemis [ __ ] vaste gamme au
niveau des améliorations les gens je
vous dis ça va être magnifique j'ai hâte
j'ai hâte bordel
dans les tous ensemble
pour la reine trouver là la fillette à
moi
mpk
québec
e
par le haut ça me semble être sa
solution en tout cas dans mes pensées
d'accord c'est pas ça oui
olalala dans quel bordel on s'est foutu
temps est au top les gens on est au top
niveau là
je fais
rebord là on avait pu accéder par la
barre l'envoie
y'a pas moyen par ici
[ __ ] je réfléchis mais c'est
impossible
a ok d'accord voilà comment l'appeler
cette paroisse teint hâlé monte
wazza oua el hadji faire défoncer en
l'air mais
à
il est toi cache cache
omer
sb aux excellents et la prixtel mon cher
le pauvre j'aimerais pas être à sa place
rouge
ouch ça fait voilà ça fait très très mal
aller à promet a annoncé que nature une
arme au top ça au top
allez hop nouvel équipement en à lens
grenade je suppose que ronge cette
personne devant la péter avec par
exemple
ok
waouh j'ai pris cher là didon talent est
déchaîné la pas content au revoir
allez on va dire ça en beauté allait
bien
pas mourir
tu dernier là bas
pour la santé il est quand même assez
puissant parfait hop on ramasse tout ce
bordel et on dégage un feu de camp on va
mesurer le faisait un bond trop stylé
allez hop c'est parti
comment l'améliorer léo vidéo fusil à
pompe moderne
ok il aurait tout de suite refusé à
pompe en mode moderne tac wa tout ce
qu'on a
capsule incendiaire a touché une capture
incendiaire au bal ouais direct pas de
souci je le fais namur et la stabilité
de larmes augmente la vitesse de
rechargement en évitant d'avoir à
chercher les cartouches individuellement
hockey va être abusés notre championnat
et il manque juste eu la cua alors là on
a mais laisse tomber on a le jeu the
weapon squad genre tatouée comme cette
magnifique en coupe et en soi mais de
quoi papa un petit on arrive à mettre
là-dedans
dans ce truc là non plus et un truc là
on a gagné avec présenté en fouillant
cadavres d'animaux à merde j'ai cru les
cadavres humains bon tant pis c'est pas
grave ça apprendre à lire trop vite on
est bon mais super bon
alors on va monter par la up here we go
serait cool de finir ça là on sort de
cet enfer qu'on retrouve notre pote tu
dégages l'usap est oh la vache
alors on est non aller au delà et la up
j'avais des grenades la tac
avec nous on ne veut pas de mal
merde
viens on va chercher ça allez go go go
si je suis enceinte emmerdes monsieur
revol évite à une caste nickel au top ça
y'a quand même vraiment énormément de
baston avec des tenues ou quad en se
noyant là il ya notamment passe avant le
roi près toutes les énigmes comme j'en
parlais avec l'iphone c'est plus des
énigmes voilà j'en mettais pas mal de
temps pour la solution n'était pas
assisté en appuyant sur un simple bouton
c'est un petit peu dommage
c'est n'importe quoi bon marché en fait
non vous savez quoi on est presque on a
presque trouvé ça mais le truc c'est que
si vous regardez cet épisode à l'heure
actuelle c'est parce que j'aurai je me
serais à terre dans la vidéo est pas
plus loin
alors écoutez on se trouve la prochaine
fois devant cette porte et on va enfin
sauver sa main ce fut long et périlleux
car tout le monde